thank you for joining us i'm john
langler this morning the criminal case
against former las vegas raider henry
ruggs was back in court he's accused of
causing a deadly crash while driving
drunk last week today prosecutors
formally filed five counts but ruggs
stayed home hector mejia live this
afternoon outside the courthouse
downtown with the latest hector
now well if convicted henry ruggs faces
mandatory prison time anywhere between
two and 50 years possibly more this is
all still in the early stages though
this morning the judge allowed the rugs
legal team to waive his presence in
court in person but no reason for that
request was given in court
no pleas were entered by the henry ruggs
legal team wednesday morning he now
faces a total of five counts prosecutors
added three additional counts since last
week's initial court appearance for
felony dui and reckless driving charges
d-a's steve olson explained a second
felony dui charge we believe that
mr ruggs's girlfriend was substantially
injured that's for the second reckless
driving as well and then the misdemeanor
prohibited person in possession of a
firearm ruggs is being monitored for
alcohol while he's on house arrest we've
learned he has been compliant so far
according to justice of the piece susan
bockham who also reminded the defense
that any missed check-ins or failed
tests will result in the removal of bail
rugs is accused of driving 156 miles an
hour on rainbow moments before causing
the crash that killed 23-year-old tina
tintor meanwhile his attorneys asked the
public to hold judgment i've had
multiple experiences where the facts
that were presented at the outset of the
case
turned out not to be the facts
so that's why i keep saying
please don't prejudge
let us do our work in the courtroom also
in a move described by the judge and the
d.a as unusual ruggs's attorneys asked
the judge to prevent the prosecution
from obtaining his girlfriend's medical
records the judge said she'll make a
decision on december the 8th
the victim's family did appear in court
this morning that's even after they're
getting ready for a really difficult day
tomorrow tina tintor will be laid to
rest tomorrow afternoon here in town
that's according to an obituary posted
by the funeral home in downtown las
vegas hector mejia live local now